let's now try to understand how we can
add it add four digit numbers to each
other so let's say i have the problem
2803
2803
and i want to add that to i'll draw a
little small plus sign here
you almost can't see it because i'm
doing it so far to the left
i'm adding that to
1443. and this is the same problem that
they have on page 24 of the book
let's think about how we can do this
so i'm going to do it simultaneously
here on in this top left corner of the
video
but at the same time i'm going to
draw it out with the place notation so
we know the the different uh
the different
number places let's say this is the ones
place
ones
tens
hundreds
i'll just write hund
and thousands
thous
let me draw some columns here so that we
don't
so that things can stay relatively neat
relatively neat there you go
okay
so how do we represent 2803
if we were to put it into these place
buckets
see we have two thousands so let me draw
that as thousand i'm gonna do everything
in the same color but the same color as
this two thousand eight hundred and
three so we have two thousands right so
that's
one thousand
two thousand and each of these are
thousands
right we have two thousands
we have eight hundreds
so let's see let me see if i can draw
eight hundreds
one
two
three
four
five six seven eight each of these are
100
100 100 100 you can't see it so i don't
know why i'm writing it but let's each
that just says 100 on each of them you
probably can't read it
how many tens do we have well we have no
tens right and how many ones we have
three
one
two
three each of those are ones
so i have just represented
two thousand two thousands eight
hundreds eight hundreds and three using
our our place value uh buckets right
now let's represent one thousand four
hundred forty three the same way and
i'll do all of those in yellow so it has
one thousand
so it is
one thousand
four hundred
so one two
three four each of these are a hundred
and once again i'm taking the time to
draw it in there although i'm sure you
can't read it and then we have four tens
right this is a 40.
so one two three four each of these are
10
10
10
10.
and then we have three ones one two
three
now that we've represented both numbers
this is just how we represented in our
in our
base 10 number system i know the word
base 10 might be confusing to you but
this is our decimal number system which
is based on the number 10 or nine
numerals and this is doing the same
thing but using our place value buckets
thousands hundreds tens and ones place
so let's add it up so first we go to the
ones place and we say well what is three
ones plus three ones
well three ones plus three ones that's
just equal to six ones right
and if we go to the ones place here we
see that we have six ones one two three
four five six
good enough
now let's move on to the tens place we
have zero tens plus four tens
well that's going to be equal to four
tens
and four tens is the same thing as forty
and when we go to the tens place here we
see the same thing one two three four
tens and this was the zero up here so we
have 40 here or four tens and that's
this four
right four tens
one two three four
six ones
and now let's go to the hundreds place
and this is where it gets interesting
how many hundreds do we have
well we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
hundreds here
and also if we said eight plus four
there's twelve well we can't write a
twelve in in one of in one of our places
in our number right we can only write
something
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 or 9. those are the
only numerals that i can put in any
given place
so how do we solve that problem
well what we can do is we can take 10 of
these hundreds
and we can cash them in for a thousand
so let's do that
so let's take this one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so let's
take these
let's take these ten hundreds
and move them over
and put them into the thousands place
well ten hundreds are equal to one
thousand
right
that's all i did i took 10 of these and
i took them out of the hundreds place
and i put them into the thousands place
and so these aren't here anymore i'll
just draw it kind of like that
so if we do that how many
how many hundreds do we have left well
we have one two left
so we have two hundreds left
so we could put two there and then how
many thousands do we have well we have
the two plus the one and then we have
the one thousand here that we had cashed
in with from all from ten hundreds so
the ones that we cashed in we could put
there
right that one is this one
and so we add up the thousands one two
three four thousand
or one plus two
is three plus one is four
and if you had you know if you've ever
learned to carry that's essentially what
we did but i really want you to
understand what happened three plus
three is six zero plus four is four
eight plus four the kind of the way i
learned in the eighties when i was in
third grade was essentially you say 8
plus 4 is 12 write the 2 and carry the
1. and that works
but the problem with that is you really
don't know what you're doing you're just
kind of doing something you know like a
robot you don't understand why that
works but the reason why it works is
you're actually saying 8 plus 4 is 12 or
you could say 800 plus 400 is 1200
and what you do is you say well i'm out
of that 1200 i'm going to put 200 here
and then the other thousand i'm going to
convert into a one thousand
and then you say one thousand plus the
two thousand plus one thousand is four
thousand and that's essentially what we
did here
let's do
let's do another uh problem actually
let's do well if i look at problem
number one on the next page it seems
like they just want to do some exercises
so let's just do a couple quick
exercises and then i'll do another
problem where we learned to
carry or i guess you could call it
regroup i don't
exactly know what the exact terminology
is
so they say they give us a bunch of
problems they say find the value of so
problem a they say is
4 2 6 3
plus 5.
well we could do this one
almost in our head right this is four
thousand two hundred sixty three plus
five this is just five right so we can
just add the five to the ones place and
we get four thousand two hundred and
sixty eight
right five plus three is eight
b
4263
plus 20.
so this is interesting so this 2 here
where is that that's in the tens place
so we could add that to
and i'm actually not going to write them
on top of each other because i want you
to understand how to do this in your
head this is the tens place we have a
sixth in the tenths place here so let's
add the tens places right the ones
places is zero so zero plus three is
three
and then the two plus the six is eight
and then you have four thousand two
hundred
and that makes sense four thousand two
hundred sixty-three plus 20. what's 63
plus 20 it's 83
right and then of course you have the
4200 in front of it
problem c
4263
plus four hundred
well we could think about it the same
way on this number there's nothing in
the ones place nothing in the tenths
place in the hundreds place i have a
four
right so all i have to do is add in the
hundreds place here
so add the four to the hundreds place
here
to the two
right this four thousand two hundred
sixty-three if i add four hundred to it
i get four thousand six hundred
sixty-three
four thousand
six hundred
sixty-three
right all i said is 4 000 that doesn't
change 2 plus 4 is 6
and then 63.
problem d
4263
plus three thousand
once again we only have there's a zero
in every place except a thousand so we
don't have to pay attention to the
thousands so what's three thousand plus
four thousand
it's seven thousand and then we just
have the 263 plus nothing else 7
263. and what what
the reason why they're giving us these
exercises they want you to realize that
you know you might think this is hard
you know i'm adding two four digit
numbers but you really just have to keep
track of one of the places at a time in
this case four thousand
plus three thousand is seven thousand
and then the rest of us you have the two
hundred sixty three
problem e
four thousand two hundred sixty-three
plus four hundred
and twenty-five
now see if you could do this one in your
head
so we could add the ones three plus five
is eight
add the tens six plus two is eight
and then add the hundreds two plus four
is six
and then you have a four thousand
there's no thousands here so it's four
thousand six hundred and eighty eight
and they have one last one
so the problem we have is
all of them are 4263
and we have plus
3425
and if you notice it's from the
different problems we added 3 000 here
we added 400 here we added 20 here we
added 5 here
right so essentially where this is kind
of the combination of all of the
problems we've done so far
so how do we do it
well we can add
first just the ones place three plus
five is eight
sixty plus twenty
is eight right six plus two two hundred
plus four hundred is six
and four thousand plus three thousand is
seven thousand this was a six so seven
thousand six hundred and eighty eight
hopefully you didn't find that too scary
let's do one more problem and this one
will we'll do the place value buckets
just to
really hit the point home so let's say
we're doing
two thousand
and forty eight
plus two
so let's say this is the thousands place
hundreds place
tens place i'll call this thousands and
this is the ones place
so how many ones do we have
in this number we have eight ones two
thousand
forty eight one two three four five six
seven eight
right that's the eight ones
we have four tens
draw a line here
one two three four each of these are
view them as a ten dollar bill maybe
we have no hundreds
and how many thousands we have one
thousand
we have two thousands
right two thousand and what are we
adding to it we're just adding two or
two ones
so this two i'll do it in magenta
we're just adding two
one two
so what do we get when we add it up
well let's think about it how many ones
do we have we have one two three four
five six seven eight nine
ten ones we have ten ones here so we
can't write a ten in the ones in the
ones digit place or in the ones place we
can only write something zero through
nine right ten is you can't write a ten
digit number where you only need one
digit so what we can do is let's cash in
or let's convert these 10 ones
what can we change them into
we can change all of these into a 10.
we can change all of these into a 10.
and then if we take all of these
convertible to 10 move it here then we
have nothing left here
so what do we have now we have zero ones
how many tens do we have one two three
four five tens
no hundreds and two thousands so it's
twenty sorry it's two thousand and fifty
and so two thousand forty eight plus two
is two thousand and fifty and that
should make sense to you intuitively
right what's 48 plus
48 plus 1 is 49 so 48 plus 2 is 50.
or another way to think about it
you know this 2000 is just kind of there
right because we're not doing anything
with the hundreds or thousands place
the other way to think about if we write
it like this 48 plus 2
you say 8 plus 2 is 10. this is kind of
the traditional way that a lot of people
have learned it maybe your parents
learned to do this way where they say 8
plus 2 is 10 you write 10 where you
write the zero you carry the 1 and you
say 1 plus 4 is 5.
now that always works but it's important
to realize what you really did when you
say this you're actually saying 8 plus 2
is 10.
instead of writing that 10 in the ones
place i'm going to convert all of them
into one more ten in the tens place and
so i have zero ones and one ten right
eight plus two is zero ones and one ten
and then i have one ten plus four tens
is equal to five tens or fifty so that's
what we did there and i will see you in
the next video